Speaker 1: Let's go next to Jamie
from Georgia. Jamie, welcome.
Speaker 2: Hi, thank you for welcoming me.
My pleasure. Yes. So, David, what I wanted
to touch on and I wanted to talk today about
was there was the rise of socialism in the US,
according to this Axios poll. Apparently, it's
like forty nine to 46 percent split between
favorably viewing socialism and capitalism.
I don't know which way it is, but either way,
what are what are your thoughts on the rise?
Speaker 1: I have to tell you, I don't know
what you're talking about,
so you're seeing the rise of
socialism as popularity. Are you saying?
Speaker 2: Yeah, yeah. Yeah, yeah. Like,
I'm sorry, I didn't. I don't think I explained
this very well. I mean, like the rise between
the rise of socialism being viewed in a more
favorable light compared to capitalism being
viewed in a very positive light. For instance,
during the Red Scare in the US, socialism was
very negatively compared to capitalism.
Speaker 1: OK, I don't have the numbers in
front of me, but I know that you're correct that
socialism is seen less unfavorably in the U.S. now
than it has been in a long time. So let's agree
that that's going on and the specific numbers
maybe, maybe we don't have in front of us. I don't
have any particular hot take on that. I mean,
listen, here's what's going on. The version of
capitalism that exists in the United States has
failed many, many millions of people. When we
look at wages, when we look at access to just
basics that people need to live, we have hunger in
the United States, there is no reason for that, et
cetera, et cetera. It's natural that people would
say, Wow, this isn't working, what else is there?
And one of the other things that there is in
theory is socialism. So it's not shocking to me,
given the version of capitalism that exists
here, that there would be people looking for
other things. As far as socialism goes, I'm not
personally a socialist that doesn't mean anything
in particular. But my point is I'm not like
looking to usher in socialism and socializing
the means of production and socialized ownership
of businesses. I'm not looking to do that. I think
a lot of the people that now view socialism
more favorably also aren't looking to do that,
and they don't actually know what socialism
is. So that's sort of my take. Not surprising.
People are looking for alternatives. A lot
of them don't really know what socialism is.
A lot of the people that claim to be socialists
aren't really like Bernie says he's a democratic
socialist. Maybe he is. But his policy
is one of social democracy, which is a
regulated capitalism. So I think there's some
confusion and there's some logic to it as well.
Speaker 2: Yes, I think that's a very good take,
man. Thank you. Yeah, I I will I will say yes,
the the U.S. in the US, what is considered
socialism has largely been incredibly stunted,
of course, due to the red scares and uber
reactionary ism that's fostered in the US culture.
But what I think that a good way to combat this
would be to educate would be to educate people
on what socialism really is. Sure. And yeah, and I
think, you know, and I would and I would classify
personally, I would classify social democracy as
not a form of socialism, but as sort of like a
sort of like a window into socialism.
When people see that this little nugget
of socialism, something that's barely even
socialism, not even the economic policies,
but just the everything else policies of social
democracy. Yeah, I think that people will be like,
Hey, so this is just a nugget of socialism.
This is really good if we have this, but on a
much larger scale and in a way that we make sure
does not end up like the Soviet Union or China,
then we can have socialism. And I think
that socialism will have even more of a
boom than it already has experience.
Speaker 1: So I don't agree with you
personally. I think that having social
democracy would lead us towards being
like the northern European countries, which are
still capitalist countries. But what I will say,
what you just said is the view of a lot of
incrementalist socialists. So for example,
there's a streamer named Ian Walsh, and when I
spoke to Ian Walsh, he said, I'm a socialist,
but if we're ever going to have socialism,
it's going to go through social democracy
so that people realize, Hey, this is the right
direction to go in. So the view you're espousing,
while it's not one I agree with, is a valid
and widely held view among actual socialists,
and I appreciate you making that point.
Speaker 2: Mm-Hmm. Thank you. My pleasure. It's
about all I had. So thank you for calling
me, David. See you. See you next time.
Speaker 1: All right. We will see
you next time. Appreciate the call.